- Watch this,
I'm going to show you
something really fascinating.
Do me a favor, Web Summit.
I want you to stand
up if the following
statement is true.
I know some of you
are fucking lazy,
but it's good circulation,
so if this
is true to you, stand up.
How many people here
now, actually get upset
when another
human being calls them?
Stand up.
Gonna wait.
I want everybody,
don't sit down yet.
I want everybody
to look at this.
These are human beings,
I'm going to repeat it
to everybody, these are
human beings that actually
get upset when
another person calls them.
The main way we rolled,
just five or six years ago.
Let's clap it up
for these pioneers.
(audience applause)
I'll tell you why I'm clapping
for that pioneer right there.
I'm clapping, because what
these people have innately felt,
and understood, is the
emergence of the most important
asset in our new ecosystem,
along with the
health of our family,
money, our religion,
and the health, which is, time.
The reason those people
stood up, and were mad,
that somebody called
them is because we
have technology now, that
allows us to actually text
somebody, and I'll call
you back on my time,
don't call me on your time.
Like, literally, like...
"Fuckin', I'll text
you back, mom!"
That kind of shit.
(audience laughter)
And so, we as business
people, in Corporate America,
need to wrap our head
around one very big truth.
The day of advertising,
stealing somebody's time,
is over.
(upbeat music)